the one thing we saw across the board
this season was there was a lot of
reinterpretation of classic English
fabrics challenge to windowpane blend
class you know and these are always you
know very typical menswear staple types
of fabrics but I love that in a lot of
cases people updated them I made them
really modern like for example Frieda in
her show you don't have that beautiful
blonde prostitute but made it a little
bit more updated by making the trousers
really skinny and the jacket was little
box your and it just looked like a new
suit to me and in Lucas the show he had
this really cool tweed look that was a
voluminous shirt on the top that was
crew neck and then ultra skinny trouser
and the thing I like about this trend is
that these topics have been around
forever but I thought there was a lot of
new and interesting fresh cuts and
treatment to them this season you should
pay attention to colors this season you
want to pay attention to our maroon and
a baby blue first of all let's talk
about maroon you know this is a
traditional obviously like very classic
color for fall winter and i love that it
was at so many shows him a lot and a ton
of shows in paris i was on hands it was
on jacket it was on top coat it was
unsure day it was really the strongest
color of the season I mean I think
maroon is a pretty easy color for anyone
to wear if you're a little hesitant
start with something smaller so i would
say a shirt or sweater and you know put
it under something navy or gray another
standout color this season was a
beautiful light baby blue this is not a
fall color it's more associated with
spring summer and i thought it was a
really beautiful soft relaxed way to
update your darker shades for the season
and get ready to wear some velvet this
season velvet was everywhere it's
something that a lot of people think of
his only
evening time but you know one of the
things that's not really interesting is
that you know Velvets fine for day they
showed it on pants at Armani they had it
on coats that coochie I think the thing
is to dress it down a little bit because
it's such a rich luxurious fabric is
paired with something really simple and
keep it really easy another key piece
for the season is get somethings quilted
weather was on Blazers pants shirts or
even these like you know great top
they're almost like these pumper tops
quilting is something that's super warm
and you know you can wear this with
anything don't worry whole thing does
not make you look fat you know the cuts
here are really slim you're going to
look good get behind it it's happening
overall the takeaway from me this season
is that it's all about simplicity
there's a really nice hair down feel to
all the shows but I like that there's a
lot of really good pieces and season
that will give you the warmth you'll
still look chic but just keep it simple
I've got a lot of really cool ideas
about how to shoot all this stuff so I'm
really excited so today attention to
details calm and you know you can always
keep updated with me on instagram and
twitter at details Matt see you next
season
you